la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Charon pour 7
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues lorsquinnet est né le monde
s'émerveillait il était la promesse d'un
espace d'échange formation de
communication et même d'éducation en
réalité internet est une perpétuelle
révolution pour l'humanité Internet est
surtout la promesse d'un espace de
liberté absolu s'affranchissant de
toutes les frontières qu'ell soit
géographique juridique voire morale pour
la presse internet est un outil
essentiel et une promesse de
développement en particulier dans les
pays où la liberté d'expression est
bafoué par ailleurs à cet instant
permettez-moi de rendre hommage à tous
les journalistes qui qui parfois
risquent leur vie pour exercer leur
métier en 2015 soit plus de 30 ans après
sa création internet offre au monde un
autre visage celui d'un espace sans fois
ni loi permettant la diffusion du pire
de ce que l'humanité a pu produire
Internet favorise l'expression de tous
peu importe leur opinion et leurs croyan
aujourd'hui le pire a atteint son
paroxisme aujourd'hui les islamistes les
plus radicaux ont épousé le projet
politique d'instaurer un califat mondial
assassinant quiconque s oppose
mais l'état islamique mène aussi une
autre guerre dont le théâtre ne connaît
pas de frontières à cause d'Internet il
bénéficite une existence médiatique sans
limite dès lors internet n'est plus un
simple moyen de communication c'est une
sphère d'expansion inouï où les
propagandes les plus fanatiques peuvent
être distilé en toute légitimité pire
internet est un sergent recruteur aussi
discret qu'efficace comme en témoigne le
nombre de jeunes Français partis faire
le djihad c'est un outil de
radicalisation et de recrutement pour
terroristes en herbe mais internet est
aussi la sphère d'une tragique émulation
d'une macabre concurrence entre
mouvances terroristes lors de la tue de
Charlie hebbdo l'un des auteurs de ce
crime affreux n'a pas hésité à faire la
publicité de son appartenance à Al-Qaïda
au Yémen la diffusion des vidéos
insoutenables et la mise en scène des
exécutions des otages sont des exemples
de cette ignoble politique de
communication dès lors internet est une
couveuse pour apprenti terroriste un
vivier pour les ennemis de la liberté
qui est pourtant l' fondement de notre
République aujourd'hui Internet est un
nouveau théâtre d'opération dans notre
lutte contre le terrorisme ne nous y
trompons pas l'objectif des terroristes
est de mettre à l'épreuve les
démocraties dans ce qu'elles ont de plus
cher l'attachement aux liberté publique
la liberté de la presse en est l'un des
fleurons oui elle est une conquête une
belle conquête notamment achevée surous
la 3e république par sa grande charte
qui est la loi du 29 juillet 1881 mais
elle reste fragile aujourd'hui celle-ci
est détournée siamment la problématique
est claire comment concilier ce précieux
acquis de la loi de 1881 et la diffusion
de publication glorifiant le gécide des
chrétiens d'Orient et des yésidistes en
Irak la destruction de lieux de culte et
des autodafé de livres ancestraux
pouvons-nous laisser fleurir et
prospérer sur Internet au nom de cette
liberté ce type de littérature dont les
atours sont les mêmes que nos magazines
électroniques il s'agit de dépasser ce
piège intellectuel qui tend à opposer
liberté et sécurité on ne peut glorifier
la liberté jusqu'à la déraison notre
responsabilité est de comprendre les
enjeux du terrorisme et d'y répondre
sans nous renier ainsi la vraie question
dépasse la seule liberté de la presse
sur Internet la vraie question c'est la
gouvernance d'Internet et les actions
que peuvent mener tant les responsables
politiques que les grands acteurs du net
de fait je veux saluer l'initiative de
Monsieur casazenu qui s'est entretenu
avec les représentants des géants du Net
que sont Facebook et Google en France
des mesures pour bloquer les sites
internet faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme ont été adoptées et je m'en
réjouis c'est un signe fort envoyé à nos
concitoyens mais aussi aux terroristes
le Web ne rime pas avec impunité c'est
aussi la preuve que nous prenons ainsi
notre part de responsabilité sur
internet il n'est pas envisageable que
les publications de l'État islamique en
langue française téléchargeable par
simple clic puissent être à la portée de
tous et en particulier des plus jeunes
néanmoins une autre question se pose
pour nos services de renseignement ces
publications et ces sites nous
permettent aussi de remonter des
filières entières pouvant démontrer les
connexions entre les différents réseaux
supprimer ces sites et empêcher la
diffusion de ces publications ne
nuirait-il pas au final à nos services
je ne le crois pas pour cela il importe
que nos agents disposent de toutes les
ressources techniques et logistiques en
outre l'action de la France ne peut être
isolée c'est une politique européenne à
minima mais aussi mondiale qui doit être
mise en place souvenons-nous que tous
les supports d'information peuvent être
utilisés à de mauvaise fin le génocide
randais a été insufflé par les ondes
d'une radio si la radio a pu servir
d'instrument de destruction il en va de
même pour internet n'importe quel
support peut véhiculer la haine nous ne
pvons nous abrité derrière la liberté de
la presse derrière la loi de 1881 pour
justifier notre passivité la liberté de
la presse est au service de l'homme de
sa dignité de sa conscience elle n'est
pas au service de sa destruction et de
ses dessins niilistes donner aux
terroristes l'accès à cette liberté ce
n'est plus défendre la liberté c'est la
confier à des faux soyeurs nous devons
être vigilant car nous avons vu que tout
est bon pour radicaliser des jeunes ont
succombé à la violence et au jihad par
l'exploration et la lecture de ces leur
voyage virtuel a ainsi débouché sur une
violence réelle notre arsenal
législatif doit donc être adapté et
modernisé plus généralement soyons
vigilant la responsabilité n'est pas la
censure car la liberté est inséparable
de la dignité humaine n'attendons pas ne
nous laissons pas avoir par des cœurelle
ou sous prétexte de défendre la liberté
nous finirions par la détruire ne
laissons pas les libertés devenir
l'instrument de leur propre disparition
je récuse toute contradiction qui nous
empêcherait justement de combattre le
terrorisme au nom du respect de la
liberté de la presse aussi je soutiens
avec le groupe UMP toute initiative
sérieuse qui défend une liberté
responsable une liberté vigilante et non
une liberté à genoux enfin je ne doute
pas que lors de l'examen de la loi sur
le renseignement nous serons au
rendez-vous nous serons créés les
conditions de sauvegarde de la liberté
de la presse et de la loi de
1881 qui nous est si cher pour la
concilier avec une autre liberté celle
de vivre en sécurité je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole